je
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va pas
et de bergson et du langage j'avais déjà
vidéo sur bergson qui portait sur la
question du temps et bien que ces deux
thèmes le temps et le langage net à
première vue aucun rapport l'un avec
l'autre mais on va voir qu'en fait ils
participent tous les deux d'une même
conception du monde
rappelez-vous ce qu'on avait dit dans la
vidéo sur le temps on avait dit que
robertson la division du temps en unité
de mesure objective constituait une
trahison de la nature réelle du temps la
naturelle du temps selon bergson étant
l'expérience de la durée autrement dit
pour bergson la traduction mathématiques
du temps va à l'encontre de la
perception subjective du temps puisque
pour nous le temps ne s'écoute pas de
manière uniforme de manière régulière
il ne respecte pas dans son écoulement
la régularité et l'uniformité qu'on lui
prête
en théorie selon bergson 7
mathématisation du temps répond d'abord
à un besoin pratique et correspond à la
tendance naturelle de l'esprit humain à
segmenter la réalité à la mettre dans
des cases pour pouvoir mieux
l'appréhender et ainsi organiser notre
action
de la même façon sur la question du
langage dax on estime que les mots sont
d'abord des outils de communication
entre les hommes mais que les mots ont
également pour effet de figer la réalité
d'immobiliser une réalité
par essence mouvante évolutive dynamique
selon bergson
ce sont tous nos systèmes de
représentations qui fige la réalité et
en figeant la réalité l'esprit humain la
dénature il place un écran entre lui et
le monde et ce faisant il le trail ainsi
pour berck sonne le langage est un outil
qui trahit la réalité davantage qu'ils
ne la restitue alors avant de voir ça
dans le détail on va d'abord prendre le
temps de faire le point sur le concept
de langage on va prendre le temps de
définir ce qu'est le langage en
philosophie et ensuite on reviendra
point par point sur chaque élément de
cette définition le langage peut se
définir comme un système de signes
permettant l'expression et la
communication d'informations alors déjà
on va
lancé par le terme de communication
parce que vous noterez que la racine de
ce mot c'est commun la communication
c'est la mise en commun par le langage
effectivement partagé et langue commune
partagée des définitions communes
c'est le seul moyen de pouvoir échanger
de l'information avec l'autre et donc
dans le prolongement de cette idée la
communication suppose une altérité à
laquelle on s'adresse
il n'y aurait pas de communication
possibles si nous étions seuls parce
qu'alors avec qui communient créton
communiqué ça veut dire faire circuler
de l'information entre les individus
ça suppose un échange une transmission
et c'est vrai que la raison d'être du
langage c'est le fait que nous vivions
en groupe
le fait que nous vivions en société
parce que pour pouvoir vivre en groupe
il faut pouvoir communiquer il faut
pouvoir échanger des informations
et donc la création d'un langage commun
apparaît comme une nécessité quasiment
vital pour le groupe et c'est d'ailleurs
l'une des interprétations qu'on peut
faire du mythe biblique de la tour de
babel
cet épisode qui nous raconte comment les
hommes se sont fédérés pour construire
une tour et ainsi s'élever à dieu les
hommes se sont entendus et se sont mis
en commun pour tenter de remplacer dieu
et c'est ainsi que pour les en empêcher
dieu a décidé de les mettre dans
l'incapacité de se comprendre la
capacité de se comprendre par la
distinction entre plusieurs langues
qu'allait faire que les hommes ne
seraient dorénavant plus en mesure de
communiquer ne serait dorénavant plus en
mesure de s'unir pour égaler dieu donc
brouiller les langues c'est le meilleur
moyen d'obtenir la mésentente entre les
hommes puisque si chacun parle sa propre
langue et devient alors impossible
d'échanger
on a déjà parfois du mal à communiquer
quand on partage la même langue
imaginez ce que ce serait si on avait
chacun notre propre langue ce serait
tout simplement invivable n'entretenons
déjà que le langage suppose une altérité
à laquelle on s'adresse et qu'il faut
pour pouvoir échanger de l'information
partagée un langage commun
maintenant se pose la question du type
d'informations que l'on échange à
travers le langage
qu'est-ce qu'on échange comme
information par le langage eh bien on
échange d'abord des indications
pratiques mais en échange également des
pensées et des sentiments
à l'origine le langage il avait une
fonction essentiellement pratique
lorsque le langage est apparu dans la
préhistoire
il s'agissait d' imiter le son d'un
élément sur lequel on voulait attirer
l'attention du groupe on reproduisait le
cri de l'animal que l'on chassait ou le
cri du prédateur qui menaçait notre vie
c'était une manière d'imiter la nature
par le son pour avertir pour alerter
pour prévenir d'un danger
c'était d'abord ça la fonction du
langage avertir d'un danger ou signifier
la présence d'un élément important
évidemment le langage s'est ensuite
développé il s'est élaborée et donc il a
pu devenir un moyen de coopération
d'organisation des hommes entre eux ils
allaient permettre aux hommes d'être
plus efficaces les efficaces dans la
chasse plus efficace dans la guerre dans
le travail et c'est vrai que si vous
prenez n'importe quelle activité de
groupe dans laquelle les membres du
groupe vise un objectif commun bien vous
savez que le plus important dans cette
situation c'est de communiquer parce que
la communication permet l'organisation
lors ce qu'aristote dit que l'homme est
un animal politique
il veut dire que l'homme est un animal
qui coopèrent parce que l'homme est
conscient que à plusieurs il est plus
fort
l'homme est conscient que seul il aurait
beaucoup plus de difficultés à survivre
donc l'union est un facteur de survie et
la coopération permet de renforcer
l'union et donc c'est là qu'intervient
le langage comme outil de coopération
comme outil d'organisation des hommes
entre eux il ya une autre chose qu'il
faut ajouter à propos du langage c'est
que le langage c'est d'abord une
convention qu'est ce que ça veut dire
là ça veut dire que les mots qu'on
utilise ils ont été créées par les
hommes
ils ne sont pas présents dans la nature
les mots sont des constructions humaines
les constructions de l'esprit il ya
toujours quelque chose d'arbitraire dans
le mot c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs que
si vous vous amusez à répéter cent fois
le même mot au bout d'un moment vous
aurez l'impression que ce mot n'a aucun
sens
vous aurez l'impression que ce mot n'est
plus qu'un son est un mot qui n'est plus
qu'un son devient un mot absurde puisque
c'est un mot qui est vidé de son sens
vidé de sa raison d'être
donc le langage est une convention mais
la convention c'est précisément ce qui
permet de convenir de se mettre d'accord
et c'est principalement ce à la fonction
du langage pouvoir se mettre d'accord
alors vous allez me dire le langage ne
sert pas seulement à se mettre d'accord
le langage peut aussi servir à exprimer
des oppositions des divergences des
désaccords je disais qu'en plus de
pouvoir exprimer des indications
pratiques le langage pouvait servir à
exprimer des pensées et la différence
entre les indications pratiques et la
pensée c'est que la pensée c'est quelque
chose d'abstrait même si la pensée a
toujours des retombées pratiques mais la
pensée et d'abstrait est par nature
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait la grande
différence entre le langage humain et le
langage animal c'est que le langage
humain peut servir à exprimer des
abstractions et donc le langage
lorsqu'il s'applique à la pensée peut ne
pas avoir pour but de s'accorder
on en a la démonstration tous les jours
dans les débats télévisés
le langage est utilisé comme une arme de
persuasion comme une arme de lutte de
combat intellectuel et dans ce cas là le
langage qui est d'abord un outil de
coopération entre les hommes
fini par devenir un outil de division
mais le fait est que si vous écoutez
cette vidéo et que les propos que j'y
tiens éveil en vous certaines pensent et
font résonner certaines idées mais c'est
bien la preuve que le langage sert aussi
à ça le langage sert à articuler la
pensée parce qu'une pensée sans mots
c'est une pensée qui ne peut pas tenir
debout le langage sert à exprimer des
indications pratiques
il sert à exprimer des pensées il sert
également exprimé des sentiments ou des
émotions et là on va le voir c'est
quelque chose qui pose de nombreuses
difficultés
on va voir ça va poser de nombreux
problèmes mais avant ça on récapitule le
langage c'est donc un système organisé
de signes permettant d'établir une
communication entre les membres d'un
groupe c'est à dire d'échanger de
l'information et du sang
et là je suis presque sûr que depuis le
début de la vidéo
quand je parle de langage vous pensez
immédiatement au langage verbal
c'est normal puisque j'ai moi-même fait
porter mes exemples sur ce langage
verbal mais se trouve que le langage ne
se limite pas aux mots c'est par abus de
langage justement qu'on limite le
langage au seul langage verbal mais
rappelez-vous ce que j'ai dit dans ma
définition j'ai dit le langage c'est un
système de signes n'est pas dit c'est un
système de mots à système de signes mais
ça veut dire quoi ainsi bien il suffit
de lire le mot un signe
c'est ce qui signifie un signe c'est le
véhicule d'une signification
ce qui veut dire que quand vous faites
un signe de la main à quelqu'un pour lui
dire bonjour vous utiliser le langage
non pas le langage oral mais le langage
gestuel vous le faites un signe
autrement dit voulu signifier quelque
chose voulu signifier votre sympathie
voulu signifier votre joie de le
rencontrer et c'est vrai que souvent le
mot singh on a tendance à l'identifier
aux signes gestuelle mais les mots aussi
sont des signes ils sont des signes
puisqu'il signifie les mots sont des
signes les gestes corporels sont des
signes
donc quand on dit que le langage est un
système de signes on parle de simu oraux
ou écrits les mots on parle de signes
gestuelle on peut aussi parler d'autres
types de signer le prendre un exemple
quand vous êtes en voiture sur la route
il y à aubord de la route des éléments
qui sont porteurs de signification qui
sont porteurs d'indications sur ce que
vous pouvez vous ne pouvez pas faire
vous voyez très bien de quoi je parle
il s'agit des panneaux des panneaux de
signalisation routière bien les panneaux
de signalisation comme leurs noms
l'indiquent
ce sont des signes parce qu'ils
signalent est signalée c'est signifier
rappelez-vous l'exemple que je donnais
tout à l'heure les hommes de la
préhistoire qui imite le son de la proie
ou du prédateur lorsqu'ils sont à la
chasse si tout à coup l'un de ces hommes
imite le cri du prédateur c'est un
signal
c'est un signal au sens où il doit nous
faire réagir
c'est ça un signal c'est une alerte mais
signal étymologiquement c'est un signe
c'est à dire c'est ce qui signifie donc
les panneaux de signalisation il vous
signifie tout un tas de choses
il vous signifie qu'il est interdit de
stationner à tel endroit que la vitesse
est limitée à 80 km/heure que vous allez
passer devant un radar donc les panneaux
sont des signaux et en signalant le
panneau signifie donc voyez que ce qu'on
appelle un signe en théorie du langage
c'est très très large c'est très très
large parce que ça va bien au delà des
mots les mots signifient mais les gestes
signifie les couleurs signifie est ce
que vous savez par exemple pourquoi on
utilise le rouge pour signifier le
danger bien tout simplement parce que le
rouge c'est la couleur que l'être humain
perçoit le mieux c'est celle qui attire
le plus son attention donc si on veut
alerter sur un danger c'est plutôt pas
mal d'employés la couleur la plus
visible
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait qu'on évite
de porter des couleurs vives sur le
front de guerre on va porter des tenues
camouflage pour ne pas signaler notre
présence est d'ailleurs on peut utiliser
cet exemple pour dire que les vêtements
aussi sont des civils ils sont des
signes d'appartenance sociale
d'appartenance communautaire notre look
notre façon nous habiller mme peut
témoigner d'une appartenance à un groupe
donc là encore c'est une manière de
signifier le langage ne se limite pas au
langage articulé
la danse est un langage la manière de
conduire est un langage
toutes ces choses sont porteuses de
signification donc maintenant qu'on a
fait toutes ces précisions utiles sur ce
qu'est le langage on va s'intéresser
plus particulièrement à la question du
langage chez bergson et donc je précise
immédiatement que l'analyse du langage
par bergson va se concentrer
exclusivement sur le langage verbal
humain c'est-à-dire sur les mots
personne ne va pas s'attarder sur tous
les systèmes de signe parce que lui ce
qui l'intéresse c'est la question du mot
car le mot est en rapport direct avec
l'intelligence
si vous préférez le mot est une
construction de l'esprit
et ça pour lui c'est absolument capital
parce que bergson considère que
l'intelligence humaine a tendance à
dénaturer la réalité c'est ce qu'on
disait au début de cette vidéo
l'esprit humain a tendance à comparer
mantei le réel il a tendance à le
découper pour pouvoir mieux
l'appréhender et on va voir que c'est
exactement ce que nous faisons à travers
le langage à travers les mots alors
qu'est ce qu'un mot un mot c'est un
outil de dénomination de la réalité le
mot micro désigne l'objet que j'utilise
pour enregistrer la vidéo le mot écran
désigne l'objet que vous utilisez pour
regarder cette vidéo
dans tous les cas le mot est un outil de
désignation de la réalité nous on est
bien d'accord que le mot micro il ne
désigne pas seulement mon micro il ne
désigne pas seulement ce micro la quête
en face de moi
il existe des millions de micro qui ne
sont pas ce micro mais qui portent tous
le même nom de micros c'est le principe
même du nom commun un nom commun il est
commun à plusieurs objets il est commun
à des centaines à des milliers à des
millions d'objets qui ont une essence
commune une essence suffisamment commune
en tout cas pour qu'on puisse les
regrouper sous le même nom
c'est la différence avec le nom propre
qui est propre à celui ou à celle qui le
porte
et si vous avez la chance de porter un
nom qui n'appartient qu'à vous si vous
êtes le seul à porter le nom que vous
portez là ce moment là vous avez un vrai
nom propre
c'est à dire un nom qui vous est propre
un nombre vous est propre
i et r donc quand on parle de noms
communs qui sont les mots les plus
courants de la langue
eh bien on parle de mot qui désigne non
pas un objet mais un ensemble d'objets
une gamme d'objets la plupart des mots
sont des noms communs autrement dit la
plupart des mots sont des mots sous
lesquelles on regroupe une multitude de
choses
partageant des caractéristiques communes
ça rejoint le propos que j'avais
développé dans ma vidéo qui s'intitule
je généralise et alors à savoir que par
définition parler s'est généralisé quand
on parle on généralise puisque quand on
parle on utilise des noms communs des
noms sous lesquelles on regroupe des
objets multiples des objets qui ne sont
pas identiques les uns aux autres et
justement selon bergson ça ça pose
problème ça pose problème parce qu'alors
ça veut dire
n'escamote totalement ce qui fait la
spécificité de ce dont on parle le mot
méprise la particularité il méprise
l'unicité de la chose dont je parle
quand j'emploie le mot arbres de quel
arbre est ce que je parle parce que des
arbres carla des millions et pas un seul
de ces arbres nette identique à un autre
or le mot ne tient pas compte de ça
c'est pour ça qu'on est obligé de
recourir à des adjectifs qualificatifs
pour préciser pour resserrer davantage
autour de l'objet dont on parle
l'adjectif qualifie l'adjectif précise
parce que si je suis sur un parking que
je dis regarde la voiture personnes qui
étaient avec moi elle va se demander si
je me moque pas d'elle regarde la
voiture quelle voiture la voiture rouge
la décapotable et chaque mot que je vais
ajouter dans ma désignation va permettre
de resserrer autour de l'objet que je
vise
on dirait on peut aussi l'a désigné par
la marque et le modèle vous avez compris
l'idée
l'idée c'est que le mot seul ne suffit
pas à désigner la chose il ne suffit pas
à désigner la chose mais surtout il ne
suffit pas à exprimer la chose il ne
suffit pas à dire ce que la chose est ce
qu'elle est dans sa singularité se caler
dans son unicité dans son existence
propre
le mot est toujours une approximation
des choses le mot est toujours une image
floue de la chose parce qu'à chaque fois
que j'utilise un mot je fais abstraction
de la particularité de ce dont je parle
je fais abstraction de ce qui fait son
caractère unique
c'est ça le problème du mot le mot
efface le mot comme la singularité de la
chose et ça c'est
la bhl non seulement pour les choses
autour de nous pour les choses concrètes
physique
mesalles a fortiori pour les sentiments
où les émotions je disais tout à l'heure
que le langage poser problème du point
de vue de l'expression des sentiments et
des émotions parce que les sentiments
sont des phénomènes intérieur donc
comment trouver le mot pour désigner
quelque chose qui nous est intérieure
pour désigner quelque chose qui n'est
pas visible et qu'il fondamentalement
impossible de connaître avec exactitude
il ya plus singulier il n'y a pas plus
individuelle comme expérience
l'expérience du sentiment c'est
l'expérience de l'unicité du sentiment
comment savez vous que votre tristesse
est identique à la tristesse de votre
voisin vous ne savez pas vous ne savez
pas parce que vous ne savez pas comment
votre voisin vie sa tristesse ne savait
pas comment ils les prouve comment elle
affecte comment elle travaille en lui
pouvait pas le savoir tout ce que vous
pouvez voir ce sont les signes de cette
tristesse et signe sur le visage dans
les yeux dans la façon de marcher ça ce
sont des signes du sentiment ce sont des
signes de l'émotion mais les signe de
l'émotion ne sont pas l'émotion parce
que l'émotion est dette intérieure et en
tant que phénomène intérieur il n'est
pas objectivables il n'est pas transcrit
petit bout par le mot et c'est ça le
problème du langage le langage est
limitée dans l'expression des phénomènes
intérieur et dont je disais comment
savez vous que votre tristesse est
identique à la tristesse de votre voisin
c'est même pire que ça
comment savez vous que vous êtes triste
comment vous savez que ce que vous
ressentez ça porte un nom qui est la
tristesse comment voulez le savoir
qu'est ce qui vous dit que ce mot est
fait pour désigner ce que vous éprouvez
là vous savez parce que depuis vous êtes
né vous avez emmagasiner des expériences
que les gens autour de vous ont qualifié
du nom de tristesse et que votre mémoire
à la rassembler sous ce mot ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous appelez la tristesse
c'est ça qui fait que vous allez
utiliser ce mot c'est ce regroupement
d'expérience ayant des caractéristiques
communes et qui vous fait penser que ce
que vous éprouvez ça correspond à ça ça
rentre dans cette case
mais sauf que le mot tristesse il est
fondamentalement incapable de traduire
la singularité de votre expérience de la
tristesse et non seulement vous ne
pouvez pas savoir si le mot vous
utilisez correspond un sentiment
identique chez les autres mais en plus à
l'intérieur de vous même ce sentiment
peut prendre des formes différentes
il prendra défend totalement différentes
et pourtant il conservera le même nom
ça ça pose problème ça pose problème de
regrouper sous un même nom des choses
différentes
d'autant que les sentiments c'est un
nuancier c'est à nuance y est de forme à
nuancier d'intensité de persistance un
sentiment n'est jamais immobile un
sentiment n'est pas figé le sentiment il
vit et donc si le sentiment vie s'ils
évoluent les ça veut dire que le mot est
inapte à le traduire
vous avez déjà été en colère bon mais
est ce que votre colère d'avoir perdu
contre un débutant à street fighter
équivaut à votre colère d'avoir été
trahis par votre meilleur ami
et est ce que la colère d'avoir été
trahis par votre meilleur ami se limite
seulement à un sentiment unique qui
s'appelle la colère est ce que la colère
ne se mélangent pas à d'autres
sentiments
la déception la compréhension la révolte
vous avez mis sous le mot colère un
sentiment protéiforme et vous l'avez
fait parce que vous êtes obligés de le
faire
vous êtes obligés d'utiliser des mots
imparfait des mots imprécis pour décrire
votre expérience et l'a signifié à
autrui mais les mots que nous utilisons
ce ne sont que les mots que nous avons
déjà entendues et que nous estimons apte
à décrire le moins mal possible ce que
nous éprouvons les mots que nous
utilisons ils sont le résultat d'un
gigantesque bouche à oreille donc voyez
que le problème du langage c'est tout ce
qu'il ne dit pas c'est tout ce qu'il ne
parvient pas à dire le mot est
incapables de pénétrer la coquille du
coeur le mot est incapable de percer la
surface de toute réalité la voyais
arriver le problème c'est le fameux
problème du malentendu qu'est ce qu'un
malentendu
tendu c'est le fait de ne pas arriver à
se comprendre malentendu
étymologiquement c'est mal entendement
autrement dit mauvaise compréhension
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans les
expressions ne pas s'entendre avec
quelqu'un quand on ne s'entend pas avec
quelqu'un fondamentalement ça veut dire
qu'on ne se comprend pas ou dans
l'expression j'entends bien quand vous
dites j'entends bien vous ne voulez pas
dire j'ai bien entendu on parlait pas de
louis j'entends bien c'est je comprends
bien et donc il ya malentendu quand il y
a mais entente sur le sens d'un mot
parce qu'un mot peut renvoyer à des
choses très différentes et parfois le
mot ne parvient pas à dire la chose
qu'on voudrait dire le résultat c'est
une mauvaise compréhension
ce qui est d'ailleurs un pléonasme
puisqu'une mauvaise compréhension
ce n'est pas une compréhension donc le
drame du mot c'est qu'il est incapable
de retranscrire la réalité de ce dont il
est l'expression le mot n'est qu'un
signe
ils signifient ils informent il permet
de communiquer de mettre en commun
mais ce que le mot mais en commun c'est
la couche superficielle des choses le
mot est toujours une photographie
superficielle des choses une
photographie qui permet de savoir
comment se comporter qui permet de
savoir comment agir ou réagir
c'est pour ça que lorsque vous arrivez à
votre boulot et vous dit à vos collègues
aujourd'hui vous êtes énervé vos
collègues ils vont pas chercher à saisir
ce qui fait la singularité émotionnel de
votre énervement
ils vont dire ok lui il est énervé
aujourd'hui je vais le foute la paix
autrement dit le mot énervement il aura
été le signe le signifiant d'une
indication pratique la demande implicite
de vous laisser tranquille c'est ça
finalement la véritable fonction du mot
lorsqu'on veut exprimer une émotion
c'est de signifier le comportement qu'on
attend en retour de cette émotion quand
vous dites je t'aime à quelqu'un vous ne
cherchez pas seulement lui transmettre
une information vous attendez une
réciprocité vous attendez un sourire un
baiser ou un mois aussi
autrement dit il y a dans l'expression
de ce sentiment
l'expression de la tante d'une réaction
d'une certaine réaction
parce que si
action c'est de dire ok ok j'ai bien
pris note
je pense que la personne en face de vous
elle risque d'être un petit peu déçu
donc même l'expression du sentiment a en
réalité une finalité pratique et c'est
ça que vous nous dire à berck sonne
c'est que le langage a toujours une
destination pratique il a toujours un
rôle fonctionnel et d'ailleurs il ne
peut avoir que ce rôle fonctionnel
parce que de toute façon il est
incapable de pénétrer l'intimité des
choses donc les mots ne sont que
d'innombrables panneaux de signalisation
composent un peu partout dans notre vie
je prendre un autre exemple quand vous
dites à propos de quelqu'un lui c'est un
con quand vous dites ça qu'est ce que
vous faites vous réduisez la personne et
vous la résumer à un terme qui est
suffisant pour savoir quelle attitude
vous devez avoir vis-à-vis d'elle
traiter quelqu'un de cons c'est
considérer qu'on n'a pas besoin de
rentrer dans la complexité de son être
c'est considéré que c'est suffisant
c'est suffisant pour savoir comment on
doit se comporter vis-à-vis de cette
personne par exemple vous allez dire lui
c'est un con je lui parle pas ou lui
c'est un qu'on ne lui parle pas au fond
de vous il ya quelque chose qui sait que
cet homme n'est pas juste un con c'est
peut-être même quelqu'un de charmant
dans certains contextes et vous le savez
vous savez mais à ce moment là ce n'est
pas dans votre intérêt d'en avoir
conscience
ça n'est pas utile d'en avoir conscience
vous savez que c'est un être qui ait
fait de sentiment d'émotion de doute
comme vous c'est quelqu'un qui est
fondamentalement irréductible à ce
qualificatif mais sûre que vous à ce
moment là sa complexité
vous n'avez rien à [ __ ] c'est pas
votre problème votre problème c'est
qu'ils vous emmerde pas donc vous allez
le fabriquer une petite étiquette que
vous allez lui coller sur le front pour
savoir comment vous comporter avec lui
et tant pis si cette étiquette trahi la
complexité la personne tant pis si vous
passez à côté de toutes ses qualités de
tous les autres éléments de sa
personnalité
tant pis si le mot trahi la réalité
parce qu'à ce moment là vous échangez la
nuance contre le positionnement quand on
est toujours dans la nuance
on ne se positionne jamais parce qu'on
peut toujours trouver de la complexité
dans tout dire
qu'un certain qu'on sait faire le
sacrifice de la nuance pour obtenir un
débouché pratique c'est faire le
sacrifice de la nuance pour savoir
comment agir
or nos dix personnes le mot a toujours
pour but d'agir
le mois toujours un débouché pratique on
ne parle pas pour dire des choses on
parle pour faire savoir des choses et ça
c'est très différent
le mot ne dit pas il signifie et ce
qu'il signifie il ne le dit pas on peut
parler beaucoup mais ne pas dire grand
chose on peut aussi dire sans vouloir
dire donc parler ce n'est pas d'hier et
dire ce n'est pas parler on peut dire
énormément avec un silence comme on peut
dire le néant avec un flot de paroles
parlent n implique pas nécessairement de
dire ni dire de parler quand on parle
beaucoup
indépendamment de ce dont on parle on
dit quelque chose on dit qu'on a besoin
de parler qu'on a besoin d'extérioriser
d'être écoutés d'occuper un espace
d'attention et ça c'est l'implicite du
langage le propre du langage c'est donc
de mettre dans des cases on met dans des
cases on colle des étiquettes
parce qu'une étiquette c'est peut-être
pas très respectueux de la chose qu'on
étiquette mais c'est quand même bien
pratique quand on a besoin de la
désigner et là je voudrais vous lire un
très court extrait d'un texte de bergson
où il parle de cette caractéristique du
langage
je cite instruments de l'intelligence le
langage représente un ensemble de signes
verbaux notant des choses que leur
aspect le plus commun et le plus banal
soient des signes fixant et figeant ce
qui change et varient or les signe
linguistique ne sont que des étiquettes
collées sur les choses les mots
désignent des genres des idées générales
correspondant à un groupe d'êtres
présentant des caractères communs mais
ils ne peuvent exprimer ni le réel
objectif ni notre psychisme profond
comme l'intelligence
ce sont des instruments d'action
l'évolution
langage depuis la préhistoire a fait que
le langage s'est affinée avec le temps
et c'est normal plus on maîtrise un
langage plus on peut travailler à le
rendre précis à le complexifier
l'histoire du langage c'est l'histoire
de la complexification du langage au
début un son pour imiter la proie à la
fin des mots si rarement utilisé que
vous les entendrez peut-être jamais de
votre vie un mot rare c'est un mot dont
l'intérêt pratique au quotidien n'est
pas suffisamment important pour qu il se
diffuse
et c'est justement le travail des
écrivains des hommes de lettres de les
maintenir en vie la nature du réel nous
dit bergson c'est d'être mouvant c'est
d'être en transformation perpétuelle
autrement dit à chaque fois que vous
désignez quelque chose ou quelqu'un par
un mot vous lui interdisez de suivre son
destin naturelle qui est de ne jamais
être identique à lui-même
on dit souvent les paroles s'envolent
les écrits restent
c'est totalement faux les paroles ne
s'envolent pas elles ne s'envolent
jamais les paroles grave elle se graver
les paroles marque de manière indélébile
le grain de la voix qui nous parle il ne
disparaît jamais rien et plus
profondément intense qu'une parole
prononcée et entendu rien n'est plus
pénétrants qu'un mot qui nous est
adressé et qui nous traversent les cris
et réfléchie l'écrit et penser la parole
est une éruption
la parole est un coup de tonnerre et
mots qui sortent de notre bouche les
mots que nous prononçons ne sont pas de
simples mots ils sont la pointe avec
laquelle nous scrutons le monde
ils sont la pointe avec laquelle nous
façonnons le monde
alors faisons
sorte que nos paroles soient plus que
des étiquettes faisons en sorte que nos
paroles soient plus que des mots faisons
en sorte que nos paroles soient une
oeuvre d'art faisons en sorte que nos
paroles soient un chef-d'oeuvre
je vous remercie
[Musique]